♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHILE GOOGLE KILLS
CONTRACTS TO HELP OUR NATION'S
DEFENSES, HELPING INSTEAD TO
HELP CHINA'S AI, AMAZON PUTS
AMERICA FIRST.
CO JEFF BEZOS OF STICKS TO HIS
GUNS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE DOD AND I THINK WE
SHOULD.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME.
ONE OF THE JOBS OF THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP TEAM IS TO MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISION, EVEN WHEN IT'S
UNPOPULAR.
WITH BIG TECH COMPANIES ARE
GOING TO TURN THEIR BACK ON THE
U.S. DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, THIS
COUNTRY IS GOING TO BE IN
TROUBLE.
>> Greg: GOOD FOR HIM.
COMPARE THAT COMMON SENSE TO
GOOGLE'S VIRTUES SIGNALING
COWARDICE.
FIRST GOOGLE SUSPENDED ITS
CONTRACTS WITH THE MILITARY WHEN
SOME WORKERS WHINED ABOUT IT.
THEN THEY HELPED CHINA CREATE A
SEARCH ENGINE THAT SENSORS
CRITICISM OF ITS LEADERS.
WHAT SUITS GOOGLE'S, SINCE THEY
WON'T MOVE ANYTHING THAT UPSETS
THEM.
THIS TECH TITAN THINKS IT'S MORE
INVOLVED IN THE COUNTRY IT
EXPLOITS.
DEFENSES SO YESTERDAY.
SECURITIES FOR FASCISTS AND THEY
ARE TERRIFIED OF THE ACTIVISTS
IN THE COMPANY CAFETERIA.
GOOGLE IGNORES THEIR HEROIC
PREDECESSORS OR TECH GENIUSES.
ALAN TURING HELPED INVENT MODERN
COMPUTING AND BROKE SECRET CODES
TO BE THE NAZIS.
THE MATHEMATICIAN CALL YOU LATER
ROCKET TRAJECTORIES.
EVEN MOVIE STARS LIKE HATTIE
LAMAR HELPED OUT.
SHE CAME UP WITH THE GUIDANCE
SYSTEM FOR AMERICAN TORPEDOES.
TOP THAT, TAYLOR SWIFT.
THESE PEOPLE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
P.R.
THEY CARED ABOUT A COUNTRY
SURVIVAL.
NOT COOL.
THEY MAY BE THE GREATEST SEARCH
ENGINE ON EARTH BUT THE ONE
THING THEY WILL NEVER FIND SPIN
SPINE.
MORGAN, YOU ARE STILL IN THE
NAVY, AREN'T YOU?
>> Morgan: I AM.
I DO NOT SPEAK ON THE HALF OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE NOW.
WE'VE DONE A FEW SEGMENTS ON HOW
GOOGLE OPTED OUT TO HELP OUT
WITH THE DRONE PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD HELP THE DRONES BE MORE
PRECISE WHICH WOULD SAVE LIVES
AND PREVENT COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
GOOGLE PULLED OUT OF THAT WHICH
MAKES OUR DRONES LAST DAYS.
-- MAKE OUR DRONES LESS SAFE.
>> Morgan: WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IN CHINA.
THE CHINESE TODAY HAVE MUSLIMS
DETAINED IN INTERNMENT CAMPS AND
DETENTION CAMPS.
I THINK WERE IN A REALLY
INTERESTING.
FOR AMERICAN BUSINESS AND IT
TIES INTO THE SAUDI CASE IN THAT
AMERICAN BUSINESSES ARE SAYING
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE AN
AMERICAN BUSINESS?
ARE WE AN AMERICAN BUSINESS OR
ARE WE SEEKING PROFIT OVERSEAS.
DO WE CARE ABOUT A COUNTRY'S
HUMAN RIGHTS RECORDS.
SHOULD WE DO BUSINESS IN
SAUDI ARABIA AFTER THIS.
WHERE DO YOU DRAW THE LINE.
WHERE DO YOU DRAW THE LINE IN
DOING YOUR COMPANY'S BUSINESS
OVERSEAS AND I THINK THAT
SOMETHING AMERICAN BUSINESSES
NEED TO ASK.
IT'S GOING TO BE EVEN MORE
CRUCIAL AS THE PRESIDENT WRAPS
UP HIS ESCALATION, THE TRADE
ESCALATION WITH CHINA OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
WE ARE IN A COLD WAR WITH THE
CHINESE AND AMERICAN BUSINESSES
NEED TO DECIDE, ARE THEY
PATRIOTIC OR NATIONAL BUSINESSES
SEEKING PROFIT?
>> Greg: YOU CAN BE BOTH.
JESSE, YOU KIND OF ARE AN EXPERT
WITH GOOGLE.
YOU GOOGLE YOUR NAME CONSTANTLY.
IT SEEMS THAT THEY WANT THE
FREEDOMS IN THE MARKETS AND THE
PROPHETS BUT NOT THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT COMES WITH
IT OR ADMITTING THAT SAFETY
HELPS IT HAPPEN.
>> Jesse: EVERYONE IS BASED
OUT WEST AND NORTH KOREA ALREADY
HAD SONY AND NORTH KOREAN
NUCLEAR MISSILES, THEY ARE GOING
TO GO LAUNCH.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO RIGHT INTO
SEATTLE, SAN FRANCISCO, OR
LOS ANGELES.
CHINESE, VERY AGGRESSIVE IN THE
NAVY SITUATION.
THEY ARE HACKING US, CYBER
WARFARE.
WHEN YOU THING ABOUT A TERROR
ATTACK, IT COULD REALLY STOP THE
PRESSES.
YOU SET IT UP NICELY.
AMERICAN MILITARY SUPREMACY OVER
THE LAST 100 YEARS HAS BEEN
UNDERWRITTEN BY PATRIOTIC BIG
TECH EXECUTIVES.
THE MANHATTAN PROJECT, GPS,
STEALTH TECHNOLOGY.
MISSILE DEFENSE.
EVERYTHING THAT YOU THINK ABOUT
MILITARY ADVANCEMENTS, IT'S
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE IN THE TECH
SECTOR THAT PUT THEIR COUNTRY
AHEAD OF EVERYBODY ELSE.
IF THAT COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THESE EXECUTIVES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE DOESN'T
LAST, THEN SILICON VALLEY
DOESN'T LAST.
>> Greg: JUAN, I NEVER HEARD
ABOUT HATTIE LAMARR.
THAT BLEW ME AWAY.
THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF
TAYLOR SWIFT BUILDING AN AMAZING
DRONE PROGRAM.
>> Juan: WE HAD BASEBALL
PLAYERS WHO WERE SPIES.
UNDER ATTACK BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
MOST OF THE TIME BECAUSE HE OWNS
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND THEN
TRUMP SAYS THE POSTAL SERVICE
GETTING RIPPED OFF BY AMAZON.
IT'S CONSTANT.
JEFF BEZOS COMES OUT AND SAYS
AMERICA IS A GREAT COUNTRY AND
WE HAVE TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY
AND THEN THE CONSERVATIVES ARE
BLOCKING IN DEFENSIVE JEFF
BEZOS.
HOW INTERESTING, HOW CONVENIENT.
>> Greg: BECAUSE WE CAN CHANGE
OUR MINDS.
BUT JEFF -- JEFF BEZOS IS A
PATRIOT.
>> Juan: SAYING THAT WE HAVE A
MORAL ISSUE IN TERMS OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION STUFF BEING USED
AGAINST PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT ONLY OVERSEAS BUT IN
TERMS OF POLICE DEPARTMENT AT
HOME, WHAT GOES ON IN TERMS OF
AMERICAN RIGHTS.
I AGREE THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT
TO SPEAK OUT AND SPEAK TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE COMPANY.
I ALSO AGREE THAT JEFF BEZOS,
WHEN HE SAYS THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP SOMETIMES HAS TO MAKE
A DECISION THAT'S NOT POPULAR,
WHAT'S THE RIGHT DECISION.
I THINK HE MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION BUT THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT EVERYBODY WHO HAS A MORAL
ISSUE IS SOMEHOW A WIMP OR
UNPATRIOTIC.
>> Greg: I DISAGREE.
THEY ARE UNPATRIOTIC AND THEY
ARE WIMPS.
>> Dana: CASE CLOSED.
>> Greg: THEY ARE BENDING TO A
FEW LOUD VOICES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT THE P.R. NIGHTMARE.
>> Dana: SILICON VALLEY IS IN
A POLITICAL AND ETHICAL
MINEFIELDS.
VICTORY IN WAR IS INCREASINGLY
DEPENDENT ON NOT JUST WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE BATTLEFIELD BUT
YOUR MILITARY SERVERS AND CYBER
WARFARE CAPABILITIES.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT, WHO DO THEY WANT TO HELP?
THE BOTTOM LINE?
ARE THEY WILLING TO HELP CHINA
ON SOME OF THIS?
WHEN IT STARTED, THE PHRASE WAS
DON'T BE EVIL.
I'M PRETTY SURE WITH THE CHINESE
ARE DOING WOULD BE CLASSIFIED AS
EVIL.
THEY CAN'T SEE THAT AMERICANS
WANT TO USE BETTER TECHNOLOGY TO
LIMIT COLLATERAL DAMAGE SO THAT
YOU AREN'T HURTING INNOCENT
CIVILIANS.
YOU CAN TARGET MORE PRECISE THEN
YOU'RE GOING AFTER TERRORISTS.
BIG TECH HAS REPLACED BIG BANKS.
THE REASON I SAY IT'S IN THE
MINEFIELD, EACH SIDE,
REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS, ARE MAD
AT THE TECH CEOs.
>> Greg: TECH IS WALL STREET.
EVERYBODY HATED WALL STREET.
NOW WALL STREET IS RELEVANT
REALLY INTACT.
>> Juan: YOU ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
AI, ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
WHAT WOULD GREG SAY ABOUT KILLER
ROBOTS BEING SENT TO KILL OUR
ENEMIES?
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE THAT
BECAUSE THAT MEANS FEWER
HUMAN BEINGS BEING KILLED.
I WOULD RATHER SEND A ROBOT.
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
SELL IT TO SAUDIS.
>> Morgan: THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN